vous avez craqué sous la pression de
tous tous ces gens qui parlaient de vous
j'en pouvais plus alors il ya peu avec
vos tweets dont qui ont fait parler
aussi le fait que vous portez un ruban
depuis vous êtes cité dès qu'il ya une
affaire autour du voile ou de l'islam en
france vous êtes cité bizarrement vous
êtes devenu voilà c'est vrai flambeau
exactement donc comment le vivez-vous ça
être un symbole devenir un flambeau
c'est pas ce pourquoi je cherche à
exister
je veux juste être moi même présenté ce
que je sais faire et c'est tout et que
si on aime on suit si on n'aime pas on
prend pas vous avez quitté la france à
la suite de toutes ces polémiques
oui je suis parti poursuit que c'était
le seul moyen âge pour moi c'est mon
échappatoire
j'aime énormément voyagé ça m'inspire
dans ma création artistique donc ouais
je voyage échoué ce trait soit vous avez
quel âge aujourd'hui mais le 24 il ya
donc vous aviez 22 ans à l'époque de la
2 cv et 20 ans à l'époque des
publications ouais c'est ce que vous
aviez dit est-ce que quitter la france
était le seul moyen de vivre sereinement
brou sereinement ces pagnes question mon
pays je pense c'est une question de paix
intérieure et j'ai cherché cherché à
apaiser par ce qui était à ma portée de
main et en l'occurrence à l'époque j'ai
eu cette opportunité de partir de france
pour un petit moment et une certaine
sérénité
vous avez souffert de tout ce qui s'est
passé autour de vous je pense vous savez
à gré j'avais regretté un moment d'avoir
fait the voice non jamais jamais
qu'est-ce que vous avez regretté alors
je regrette rien je regrette rien je
prends les choses comme elles viennent
et j'apprends à vivre avec